forty-two seconds of logos mostly for
companies that probably don't exist
anymore America is an irradiated
wasteland tell me something I don't know
also narration mega bloks mega highways
megalodons mega city one clever name did
you have a contest among schoolchildren
or did you just all immediately realize
the brilliance way better than what I
would have gone with which would have
been something like disease appleís or
dirt city or we are still soaked
convulsing joking dread perfectly
describes my first sexual encounter the
men and women of the Hall of Justice
well at least in their pursuit of
justice they aren't wasting tons of
money powering a giant eagle light sign
outside their building wait big are also
huh
Justice Superfriends call and probably
the comics Super Friends was based on
also called and my point his Hall of
Justice has already taken two weeps
juries executioner's clerks typists
coffee vendors if we weren't having so
many issues of music lately I'd cut in
the score from matrix reloaded on
Trinity reverses course and drives the
motorcycle against traffic it goes like
this and dick attending the contingent
dundun dundun driving erratic suspects
are under the influence of narcotics
mind you they are on narcotics but
seriously how would he know this pretty
sure he's a judge and not a doctor Jim
this movie is fun the editing of this
early car chase scene not thought
vomit-inducing how are these other cars
just driving like it's a normal Monday
morning no one's slamming on the brakes
are swerving out of the way of automatic
weapon fire how exactly did they think
they lost him they've been driving about
45 the entire time Tran step-daughter
and then we're magically no cars
anywhere near or around this vehicle
when it wiped out all over the fucking
place even though we've seen a steady
flow of mega traffic for the entire
opening of the film
food courts zooted dog you want a very
good negotiator Jesse you know why you
got no right there are many many cool
things about this movie but these
opening scene villains are not one of
them it's as if they had some leftover
villain scraps from Robocop 3 I said ha
if you could fire into dudes mouth was
there really any reason to use the hot
shot round instead of a regular bullet
other than to alert the audience to the
fact that these judge guns have multiple
types of rounds futuristic health code
standards casual blood sweeping I am
sick and tired of movies making mutants
out to be scorned worthy by the very
nature of their mutation they didn't ask
for this she's the most powerful psychic
we've ever come across by a huge margin
I guess Miss Cleo didn't survive the
radiation I want you to take her out for
one day in the field what could go wrong
a rookie judge on assessment is likely
to be involved in armed combat 1 5 don't
survive the first day 1 in 5 it seems
like terrible odds would want to be a
judge 41 seconds of slow motion water
shenanigans 12 serious crimes reported
every minute 17,000 per day hold up
17,000 serious crimes per day in a city
with 800 million citizens that's a crime
rate of I mean so low it's
mathematically zero this movie makes it
seem like the crime outnumbers the cops
so bad it's near a breaking point then
throws out statistics to suggest the
crime here is pretty minimal overall
it's both comforting and frustrating to
know that no matter how bad society gets
as a whole skateboarding will always be
popular to a handful of people
unemployment rate of 96% and more than
half the residential levels here are
classed as swamp you think 96 percent
unemployment here honestly surprise the
slum percentage isn't higher nothing
just a year to open the top floor in a
block and started working our way now
how did she get up to the top in the
first place and with enough firepower to
take over did she parachute in movie
yadda-yadda is a lot of and thinks it's
raw style will make you forget it mostly
does so the slow-mo just works
automatically even a hit of acid or
shrooms takes at least 25 minutes to
kick in so I've been told only where did
that pink dragon come from Sarah helmet
can interfere
psychic abilities think a bullet might
have a feel with some more almost human
would be excellent at cinemasins also
couldn't she have the helmet with her to
put on when her psychic abilities aren't
needed for instance when she's being
shot at I will say this for the movie
the slo-mo drug plotline gives it a
reason for the action movie slow motion
cliche which leads to some really cool
effects like the skin rippling and the
ensuing gun battle that deserves a
cinema this is simultaneously fake and
grossest hey she stole her superpower
from David Dunn wait is this the real
stealth sequel to unbreakable discount
Donnelly's holy judges no no no no he
seriously just saw them now what's
copper wire origami really enough of a
distraction to not see an entire
gunfight ah whatever that is hot
blueprint file action fine this guy is
sleeping on the job but there are other
people in the room no one saw the screen
come on this seems like a really
dangerous way to conduct a test it's a
fake test but she doesn't know that and
my point is that for a real test these
cristela cops and firemen to ignore
emergency signals from a building that
houses 70,000 lives so they're taking
Mama's assassin down to the ground floor
here but remember those other seven
people and four corpses from that same
apartment they called the meat wagon for
what about them the corpses will wait
but there are a handful of cuffed perps
in that apartment for the rest of this
movie warned Chet get up you're headed
for the cube I get the dread is Dudley
cooking dear right but come on he's got
to deal with a possible murderer that
skin three people alive and he's gonna
give a guy for essentially sitting
what's going on okay you tell me your
only thing psychic what is this fresh
hell how do i compute what these numbers
mean why did they start keeping time so
differently in the future
shielding must be blocking their
transmissions because that's what you do
during emergencies you block down
residential towers and block all radio
signals in and out design this system
aspirin if judges sit tight
Foreman makes no difference you're mine
yeah but after the judges are killed and
Peachtree is back open won't more judges
come and take out mama I don't think she
thought this through very well
holy the buildings on lockdown shields
are preventing radio signals from going
or coming but the fucking elevators
still worked
I want the North and East corridor
totally covered Oh younger fatter Armand
Assante is almost certainly about the
docks so you doing a compliant judge as
ten of us only two of you but the judges
this is like an imperial droid talking
smack to a Jedi just because he's got a
dozen droid
with him I mean the fire bullet and now
the stun grenade feels like this movie
is more about gadgets than the story
he's got something new for every
scenario you could have called it
utility belt the movie Iran Oh sighs you
already did
doctor is addicted red and dreads duty
and Red's disciple and their detainee
and it's devastating to their desire to
delay death switch weapon to science a
mode is better now is to go children
except Mama has control of everything
including the cameras and microphones so
what's to stop her from just yelling out
your location constantly why isn't she
doing that right now actually and don't
shoot unless you're gonna hit Wow
exactly what my college girlfriend said
to me during her extra mean during sex
phase I said he says it's broken but it
works as long as you're hitting a button
above level 75 how convenient may need
to get to the top and the secret
elevator with a glitch will help them do
that much more quickly
of course Anderson killed this woman's
husband because movie MA you better come
quick just a minor variation only you
better come take a look at this cliche
where are they now I don't know what
they seem to be moving their way up the
block the building has all the
surveillance equipment but ex machina
has no way of knowing that they are on
the service elevator that's not good
full lockdown they're going nowhere
awesome rad suite why didn't you do that
immediately back when they were on the
ground floor or the first time they got
in an elevator I tried to do this clean
but they wouldn't let me so no we do it
I see in what scenario would this be
clean and do we really have a villain
pooh-poohing the heroes because they
didn't want to be brutally murdered it
just seems like non-productive thinking
this guy tries to rattle his captor by
talking about basically the massive rape
she will receive by his criminal buddies
if they catch her and I'm just over here
like god damn even Avon Barksdale wasn't
this evil you sir need the Holy Spirit I
was trying to shock you out of thinking
about this but she can control what she
chooses to concentrate on right because
if not with as many people as she has
past and peach trees she should be in
psychic overload at this point so she
has big-ass guns but she's gone all in
here with these things you can't easily
and quickly move these big-ass guns to
another location so if you don't kill
Dredd here which you obviously won't
then you have wasted these guns and now
you are the ones who are the ball
lickers
and CG blood looks soaking bad I miss
the days of that neon orange they used
in a lot of the 70s cop films that guy
hid behind a table sure why not mama is
now a better gunner on the 50 Cal than
any of her henchmen of course make
perfect sense seems good
time as any for they survive this in
fact this entire film could be retitled
they survive this so let's just go ahead
and tack on 20 additional sins you might
say that's arbitrary and I would say
welcome to cinema since hope you stay a
while
to avoid being shot they both willingly
jump out of a hole in the building
thankfully they land on a skateboard
park patio built on the upper floors but
also couldn't they have died by just
sliding down the building to the ground
I mean look how fucking unique and
random this patio skatepark is the odds
they jumped out a hole and landed here
astronomical where are they now what
they blocked off from going really
anywhere except for the side of the
floor that's been destroyed and I know
he threw that one guy to his death but
where's the rest of Mama's crew that was
looking for them I'm not saying it's not
possible they got away safely but I am
saying the movie just yachty out of the
out of the last 10 minutes or so you
leave it to me he doesn't have to speak
FairPoint in fact wouldn't this be her
strong suit she could be in the corner
of the interrogation room pulling out
thoughts as the questions are asked in
fact if she's this good and that's this
strong of an ability isn't sending her
out into the field a bit only
unnecessary and potentially wasteful
side if anything were to happen to her
the whole department is wasted a very
valuable resource welcome to the inside
of your head it's kind of empty in here
did Anderson just create her own cerebro
because it looks like Anders have just
created her own cerebro you've given us
two options defend or hide this is
really the best scenario to pause for
all these teaching moments this seems
like a super convenient time for
Anderson psychic abilities to not be
working wholly at what point does the
height of the building start to put the
building's very existence I can shut
down the whole system but if you let him
talk I can trace which terminal he's
using okay but also you have all those
cameras right and complete system
control after murdering the dudes and
faking the emergency testing so why
can't you pinpoint where he is without
him needing at all judgment time I would
give this movie all the sins back if he
would say it's judgement night and
Emilio Estevez and Cuba Gooding jr.
showed up for no reason
the fashion police cited this guy twice
once for being a discount Aziz Ansari
cosplaying as Vincent Vega and a second
time for a more generic offensive
spotted in public wearing a bad wig
incendiary also wired all this guns
rounds incendiary
whyever fire any other type of round
while hogs dark you're prepared to
testify to that sure because the movie
didn't have enough villains let's throw
in four corrupt
with 20 minutes left in the movie just
for shits and giggles chunk on it Fred
Jesus this movie can be fun at school
but it has one liners they wouldn't have
used in the Stallone movie if you didn't
get killed today it was gonna be
tomorrow oh is it gonna be today after
that secondary villain is talking when
he should be killing cliche what's the
price of a judge these days well if
you're only worth what people are
willing to spend when looking at the
box-office for this film I'm guessing
about 350 so the meat grinder going meat
comes out the other this is also known
as the Fargo dilemma yeah I'd be
breaking a sweat if you hadn't just run
out of bullets and he knew this how I'm
sure the movie will explain no ok then
carry on on the piercing if you're doing
some judge on judge action why with the
gun ever not be on armor pieces also
judge on judge action wants the name of
my defense team in college Mock Trial
wait wait are you kidding me
did he just say wait well it worked
didn't it the code to mamma's chambers
is four nine four three six in the
future the drug lord of a seventy
thousand resident tower society who has
built a 10-inch steel combination wall
to protect her used a five digit pin
this entire level is rigged with enough
high explosives to take out the top
fifty stories man it's a shame that this
movie couldn't come up with a climax
less generic then I've rigged explosives
and I've got my finger on the button
I heart stops beating the building blows
everyone in it hatch that's kind of a
dick move though if you end up dying of
natural causes also this is essentially
the opening of demolition man right just
with less yellow hair and Beetlejuice
pants
this is far too beautiful to death for
such an ugly character speaking about
her soul not her face say boss how will
folks know that Dredd was right about
the transmitter not working from that
distance you mean other than the
building not blowing up yeah and let's
show that wrist thingy blinking for
several seconds like something's wrong
with it look color Jesus teri make a
decision for once but seriously how does
this work and why even chance it at this
point couldn't he just take her in alive
and they can figure out how to disarm
the explosives he doesn't have to kill
her right now they can carry out her
death sentence once they've made sure
everyone else at peach tree survives
your assessments now over that thing
comes off that easily and it never came
off this whole movie even on accident
what a who'd you call it in at 10:24 I
thought I better check it out hours
later megacity one narration and
narration we already heard in the
beginning of the movie bookended
repeater asian nobody is taking dates
it's a bunch of guys going to a boxing
match that's it we have a positive ID on
three suspects wanted on multiple counts
any judges please respond survivors of
the nuclear fire called the war Judgment
Day
they lived only to face a new nightmare
the war against the machines I always
get nourished on a beautiful woman uses
a pair of pliers near my balls what such
panner to me kid one tiny crack in the
hall in our blood for 13 seconds
all of justice I should have been born a
man I'd rather face a thousand swords
than be shut up inside with this flock
of frightened hens I'm gonna stop this
guy my god do we really suck or is this
guy really that good